hey gang it's your old pals uncle hank
and kippy just want to thank you for
tuning in to ru garbage
yeah guys make sure you subscribe that
way you get the episode as they come out
you can also go to gasdigitalnetwork.com
use promo code ayg
to get bonus content and get the
episodes before they come out and hd
streaming
do it yeah welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley we got a hot one
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast
this is a little show we called are you
garbage to show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and find if they grow
up classy
or if they're a complete piece of [ __ ]
which i'm leaning towards
today i'm your host h foley coming at
you on a beautiful day here in the east
village gash digital [ __ ] studios
in the big studio let me tell you as i
said on the last episode
don't let the [ __ ] rumors fool you
new york city is alive and well baby and
we're taking the [ __ ] city back
starting right [ __ ] now
my co-host just a small town kid that
made good here
in the big apple all right he's a young
kid
married guy good looking kid all right
got some nice eyebrows nice t-shirt let
me tell you something folks
next time you're reaching for a best pal
you [ __ ] make it a kippy because this
kid stays in the fridge
for a long time no expiration date on
this guy
give it up for mr kevin james orion
thank you very much h belushi
[Laughter]
jesus christ dude you are unraveling but
i'm happy
to be here thanks for everybody for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes get
those [ __ ] numbers up
yeah also end of the quarter let's go
get a [ __ ] bonuses coming i'm the
boss breathing down my [ __ ] neck
um and then also full video available on
youtube you can subscribe there as well
and also special special very special
announcement yes we're doing
yes fan listener contest yup uh
we're looking for the best garage fridge
as you know garage fridges are big in
our hearts and our world and our mind
over here at ru garbage so please you
can send uh up to a 30 second video to
ru garbage at gmail.com
we'll take the best we'll go over them
on air we'll take the best
after what a couple weeks we'll let it
run i don't know just [ __ ] get them
in how about that
okay you don't what do you need three
weeks to send to take a [ __ ]
30-second video in your garage
and then we'll take the best five we'll
show them on the air and then we'll
decide who is the winner yeah and the
winner gets uh
you know they get a clean living and uh
garbagio t-shirt that's right any size
you want up to three x which i gotta i
gotta talk to the boys about that
i got a couple of the big boys online
hitting me up saying yo foley
where's the [ __ ] four and five no
some dude asked for a 6x
i said buddy big man i like it yeah what
the [ __ ]
you can't be making extra you can't be
making requests at 6x you take what you
get no we're trying to be comfortable
here dylan all right i like to [ __ ]
stretch it out a little bit
whatever so guys get them get those
submissions into ru garbage gmail.com
we'll go over them
uh you'll also see it on social media
and stuff like that but are you guard we
appreciate
fridge contest is [ __ ] now open get
those [ __ ] videos in
and we love you guys we appreciate
everybody who bought a t-shirt and we
could not be more excited to have our
old pal
our very incredibly special guest here
with us today a family show
a family [ __ ] show we've been squad
since jump street the kid used to
[ __ ] throw up uncle hank at
roosevelt's down there in [ __ ] philly
he was one of the only guys outside of
our crew
that was [ __ ] nice to me all right i
don't know if he knew because i could
procure
certain items maybe late at night
i knew a couple of guys in the badlands
if you know what i mean
take a ride with hank down to felton
street gang he is the host of the
amazing podcast you
[ __ ] it you know him you love him very
funny stand-up comedian all the way from
philadelphia pennsylvania
give it up for mr brian six everybody
hey
how are you what's up buddy thanks for
coming in thanks for having me round two
brown
try this again for the listener all
right we did uh when uh when we were
independent operators
uncle hank and [ __ ] before we went
corporate
we were out on our own a couple of guys
out on the range we had a patreon i
don't know if you know
yeah before we start with the suits and
[ __ ] we uh we started our patreon and
uh we wanted to have brian i was one of
our guests
and i guess you know all the [ __ ]
city specials and [ __ ] pops blew
ribbons in his head
but then like a few weeks ago he was
like yo where's my episode
people are hitting me up i was getting
tagged in a bunch of [ __ ] on twitter
people were like where's
his episode people were looking people
looking for a kid
so we thought it was only fitting to
bring the big guy back and uh
and and share the garbage with the world
yeah okay
because you sir are in fact pure
oh yeah unadulterated garbage are you an
uncle by the way
not yet no because you're you're you got
[ __ ] not married philly uncle
yeah yeah that's the outfit right there
come on that t-shirt
that guy trying to get it together
still living at mom's for a couple of
weeks yeah you got outlaws on your shirt
yeah uncle let me point that out i saw a
video uh
six and the boys uh shane gillis [ __ ]
o'connor mccusker whoever it was
you guys go to this [ __ ] low-level
[Laughter]
racetrack they don't even look like cars
that's my problem
with the amateur race circuit i think
nascar
[ __ ] ford versus ferrari those were
like boxes
yeah they're sprint cars that's how
they're designed that's sprint cars
dudes that make them in the garage
racing look at this merch
this could double as a bong company by
the way
any any company that uses the crazy
clown or whatever that's
[ __ ] real it's all just clip art and
[ __ ]
uh but i grew up going to the races my
stepdad was uh he's up there
now going flemington okay uh used to be
a dirt track and then they got their act
together
paved it up you know a little bit of
asphalt but it was always awesome when
they used to do
they had like the demolition derby oh
okay i was a kid but i would do to go
back to that now
dude i see i see those posts of you guys
hanging out at the [ __ ] racetrack and
i with
[ __ ] cold blood lights and [ __ ] i am
so jealous
yeah so jealous yeah people watching
alone is
is there is there medical professionals
there in case yeah i mean the second
time we were there guys you went another
guy
guy got killed yeah car flipped over and
uh stomped them
jesus he had retired three days prior to
that he was a teacher up there
and it was nice for actually the first
time we tried to go guy died we couldn't
even go in
so the second time we went the car flips
and this guy's just sitting there like
retirements crowds
oh [ __ ] oh man that sucks wait a minute
wait an audience member got killed yeah
what yeah he flipped the car flipped
over i mean you gotta remember these
cars
the way they are the spring cars they
have to control the little flaps on the
top so when they
they only sprint on the straightaways
and they obviously drift on the turn but
they when they start to slow down the
drift
look out because if you don't hit it
right it's like you
yeah it's like a dune buggy with like a
paper airplane on top it killed a
teacher and they're back up operating oh
that happens like every other week
people die there
yeah i think one of the tournament is
called blood in the mud
dude that is [ __ ] pure trap oh yeah
it's great
holy [ __ ] robin's racing daddy so we
know you
listen come on come on we go back along
come on
way before you guys sold out to the
e-boy
shout out to guest digital lewis jay
gomez promo code ayg
um yeah we're garbage all right we're
philly comedian
garbage yep but refresh my memory what
the uh what the origin story of brian
six is
uh and start with the name because i
thought you had told us isn't that
that's an ellis island thing yeah it was
changed when it was like was it before
brian five come on
[Laughter]
folks we're doing comedy hi oh got your
nose promo code ayg
no i was from the from the stories i've
heard it there's a million different
stories but it was apparently shortened
that ellis island was my great
grandfather other than that i don't
really know
liv know what the last name was uh it
was some italian like sickly
something yeah definitely it's funny
because there's always my wiener
you know your cystic fibrosis you know
your trash wouldn't because my mom does
that too she'll try to hype up the foley
origin story that's just dirtbag your
grandfather
you know he worked with muhammad ali and
they came over
in 1812. what was he a cup man what are
you talking about spraying him with a
hose
he was at work now he was involved in
boxing and this
and that and then like i remember going
to a family reunion there was like a
picture of like this old guy and it's
like
he fought in the war of 1812 it's like
get then you
then you get some [ __ ] cousin banged
up at a wedding time oh you're a real
story
yeah yeah that's your mom after a couple
of [ __ ] chardonnays trying to church
up your [ __ ] derelict family
yeah we don't need we don't we're not
even good enough for that they weren't
royalty then you landed a [ __ ] split
level of bluebell okay and you were
[ __ ] dirt bags to begin with
edison took it all no nothing on the
tesla joke all right
so philly family was fully born yeah
yeah
you're a huge family yeah very big
family very my my dad's my dad had seven
sisters my grandmother came from a
family of 17.
um 17. yeah she's a grandmother yeah she
has 16 siblings
what yeah my dad is my dad is something
that's like 60 something
first cousins his young my grandmother's
youngest brother is like three years
older than my dad that's all
that's where he got his first fake id my
uncle head holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] did your great grandfather
do not wear condoms
baby dude played it what the [ __ ] do you
do for work for 16 kids was it will
smith
it was back in the day dude you could
have been like a baker and you know you
made enough money yeah they all lived
together they all had a giant house with
37 people living in there so it's like
everybody put in a buck there's rent and
dinner for two weeks i guess i don't
know that's [ __ ]
that's a philly garbage fairy tale right
yeah
they had above ground pool that was the
worst living though
yeah but you got 16 kids i don't know
about the ground floor not with 37
people in it
everyone's pissing in there it's just a
horse trough
doing the dishes in there too that's why
they're swimming
[Laughter]
someone's washing jeans read it give me
the salad plate
oh that's [ __ ] true is it trash is
putting clothes out on the line
trash i don't know why no no i mean if
you don't have a dryer that's yeah
that's how you got to do it you know
my mom does this sometimes now okay when
she washes
dirty panties i'd love to see that line
of clothes look like a top of an airport
looks like an old carnival [ __ ] flap
flapping around
coming into the backyard [ __ ] pirates
of the caribbean
davey jones's ship coming in calling the
homeowners association
flying the black pearl that's her
underwear
[Laughter]
[Music]
no what my mom does is we don't have a
clothesline anymore
so we have like an awning over our back
door crash
trash wait wait wait she puts him on
hangers and hangs him up there oh yeah
yeah dude that's trash i mean if you
have a if you have a clothesline you
know whatever that's that's fine that's
whatever
fresh limited but dude if you're [ __ ]
have you got a set of hangers for
outside
a whole different set like a hot tin
awning
burning in the [ __ ] yeah what's she like
blouses and [ __ ] uh well a lot of see
okay here's the thing
now with my girth lately i can't really
use it lately
i can't use the dryer lately i can't use
the dryer for my shirts because it
shrinks
they shrink up so she hangs i think
you're just growing each wash
[Laughter]
goddamn tide pods you ever notice
everything but him they shut the dryer
shrinking it
never the cheesesteaks well be that as
it may all right i
was i wanted to know what you gentlemen
thought about that is hanging close up
outside garbage
i don't think so we did it for a while
we had a dryer in the summertime my mom
would do it i remember that
because it's saving money she eats it's
nice get that fresh oh yeah i liked it
yeah nice little crisps to it yeah i
mean living now how many brothers and
sisters do
i only have an older brother and a
younger sister we're like the weird ones
of the family because everybody else had
like a minimum four or five kids
yeah what do they do your brother and
sister my brother
uh runs a marble company for a bunch of
greeks
yeah and uh greece got their hand in
some marble horrible
yeah a horrendous business don't ever
wouldn't even promote them on this they
they [ __ ] up he just got new kitchen
counters they [ __ ] the cut up on that
this past weekend
he goes i assigned this job to you and
you still [ __ ] it up
yeah uh and then my sister works for
like a cancer research company in center
city okay
good yeah that's nice what were you
gonna do we never we don't really ask
comics
i have my own i actually uh own my own
company with my buddy
sheetrock now online marketing ah
yeah what yeah yeah for like the last
three years
for the last three years yeah you got
you own your own company yeah we got an
llc
and me and him did it we were doing it
before cotton had an llc too
yeah i remember like llc is a big deal
there was never any money in that i
remember the debit card that shayna
for the listener foley and our other
buddy chris cotton rest in peace used to
run a comedy ponzi scheme
and i was at the bottom of it i was
supposed to be able to get fifty
[ __ ] steak knives quit bitching i was
supposed to be able to get 50 bucks at
the end of every week
yeah go check the bank account it was
negative three hundo
[Laughter]
talk to mnuchin all right i don't know
what to tell you
but what do you think what would you
have done if you didn't become a comedy
i was in finance i worked for jp morgan
for like four or five years yeah holy
[ __ ] what a
stress like that pretty much yeah you
have
you have a very distinct philly
cigarette voice
absolutely and mine comes out even when
i talk like i get bigger when i talk to
you
uh there's not much you can do or like
you have to be really good at what you
do oh we're gonna get past that
yeah yeah i faked it till i made i don't
know why i even
got hired there i actually went in for a
job interview
with a full-on jump suit i was like
where's the clock huh
phil's are on at three how are you guys
hiring yeah so
they hired me as like an analyst like a
basically a pencil pusher like
very low level you went to college yeah
but not for anything with i could barely
[ __ ] balance a checkbook at that
point so i went in just being like all
right let's see if this works
called me back they're like yeah you're
in i was like i don't have much faith in
this company but here we go
he was going to be the [ __ ] fall guy
they were saying oh yeah they were
saying they were setting him up to be
the [ __ ]
my officers had a phone on the ground i
was like this is familiar
first thing that he went through was
open up a bank account in cameroon
yeah is your new partner bernie madoff
get over here
but side note i was on the phone with
them the day the fbi raided them made
off
i had a buddy over there that we worked
with yeah and i called him and i was
like
so uh what's going on he's like not much
they come and take the phone while
you're talking
he had to hang up he was like i just
popped he popped a 25 year old scotch
and a client had given him at like eight
in the morning because they
were in the building you weren't allowed
to leave and he was like i gotta hang up
uh i was like i know that sucks dude all
right later
jesus christ wow yep yeah no no wait
when the housing market crashed
i hung on for like another year and then
they just you know they were chopping 20
000 people a day
and that was it and then basically i
kind of floated along
and then i got into online marketing
which was easy as [ __ ] and i figured
me my buddy chris were good at he's
non-comic guy he loves to work he's got
a family
and uh he does all this [ __ ] i sit back
and i'm like am i right
that philly accident you're right it's
coming out so much man
you have to talk about not working yo it
comes out
and i gotta lie to you and then you
started doing comedy somewhere around
what oh
yeah like uh like 2009. it was like i
guess a year and a half before laugh
house closed
okay school was out i got nine something
yeah um yeah
and then met you guys and yeah that's
been it
that's pretty uh jp morgan i didn't know
you had that side again yeah i actually
just won a settlement with them i was
talking about this one
this is trashing people i didn't they
had
they i have my 401k i have my 401k still
with them
uh-huh even if you guys got a 401k yeah
i mean my buddy
my buddy who still works there handles
it and apparently there was some
misusage of funds
with the jp morgan 401ks and i fell into
that category and apparently i won a
settlement
so september 22nd i'm getting some cash
it might be like 40 bucks
whatever bite your beak daddy hey that's
a couple of [ __ ] sixers right there
yeah dude you know it but you can't take
it out of the 401k that's the problem no
no this would be settlement money this
wouldn't go into that
go buy some scratchers it's not going to
be 40. you know what it is it'll be
probably around what was in there i
would assume i don't know though i have
no idea they settled at around 9 40.
uh i mean it might be a few grand but
that's about it
they're calling you mister hit me up on
the 23rd right yeah
get some new are you garbage t-shirts
yeah we're looking for
angel investor by the way he's trying to
we're trying to go global
and where did you go to college penn
state main campus yeah
straight full straight through did we
ask you this no i
didn't i didn't finish what do you know
oh come on you didn't graduate how did
you get a job at jp morgan
without i lied on my resume yeah what do
you think honesty is like he's like
all of a sudden he's gonna be honest all
the time i didn't think i was even gonna
get the [ __ ] job so i was like yeah
graduated
he's in there like ben affleck and
goodwill hunting retainer
i'm like you're all suspect who's got
cash on them
well i got no gas in the car after
medical school i decided i wanted
to finally uh that's funny i didn't even
think he went to college he even
attempted
yeah attempted or ever had a job yeah
yeah yeah i was like
i would have pegged you for like [ __ ]
chi institute
maybe no no no i mean i did my share of
manual labor going off because all my
uncles and cousins are all roofers and
contractors so it's like
yeah i got in trouble in school i was on
a [ __ ] roof yeah
i was digging ditches that's yeah it
sucked you remember the kids in high
school that i don't know if
because i'm older but like there was a
certain point in high school where you
could go
like you can let black people in finally
you knew
you weren't going to college it was
going to be something in vocational
and there was a separate school yeah oh
yeah
yes and they would those kids could like
they would like stop at mcdonald's for
lunch and [ __ ] they could smoke cigs it
was like
in as a regular high school kid tech
school was like lawless
yeah they were like adults yeah and then
you see the the the class of people are
going there it's like
never mind yeah it's all like it's like
they're drinking but they're already
legally allowed to
yeah yeah yeah nuts i was like they were
driving to school in seventh grade
you're like what the [ __ ] is timmy doing
they're taking tests on like contracting
it's like what is this
so say some lady's breaking your balls
about the job say you can't get a permit
from city hall whose do you talk to
here's the bars you drink at before 7
a.m
all right jp morgan yeah all right well
let's let's
let's get into this with a little bit
because uh this is one we've been
talking about what did you get on your
sats
uh 11 40. that's what i got really yeah
yeah yeah i lucked out on that now
you're 12 40. no you gotta get four i'm
sorry 14 40. you got like
14 40. yeah well it's changed now right
it's not 16.
i never mind well back then the top was
1600 you were probably 1600 too that was
perfect because it's not switched
now no mine was 1600 i got an 870. i'm
just going to 878.7
and still got into college a good school
kid can barely tie his own [ __ ] shoes
870 is tough but i only took it once
all right that's that yeah how many
times do you listen to that and it was
the night after a really big game
of what
[Laughter]
it's a rough we were it was nine-nine
busta rhyme and i was in the zone
oh you didn't do like psats like that
that was like the preview that was the
cashmere what are you talking about
no i didn't they tried to send me you're
you're dumb they knew it they said he's
got to take them legally
they knew it they tried to send me to
like some sylvan
like someone that sylvan stuff was bad
yeah man
did you feel like there was something
wrong with you when you walked in there
there is you're at sylvan learning
center
there was like weird books everywhere
and like other than books
they're just hardbacks it's a dictionary
if it ain't highlights i ain't reading
it so wait you're telling me there's no
pictures in these books
but yeah they tried to send me to some
tutor before i took it and i went like a
couple of times you're even starting to
talk like
them too some tutor yeah hey was that
tutor
was she [ __ ] happy she have a nice
[ __ ] rack on here yeah then i took it
once on a saturday in the cafeteria it's
oh we don't need the [ __ ] nine hour
description are you bombing the sats
you act like all of a sudden he's gonna
be like and then i got a 1600.
he's like so i wake up i can't find my
lucky shirt i had to go
you stink you're dumb move on
eleven forty that's pretty good yeah i i
sucked at taking tests i didn't know
this about you at all i thought you were
just like [ __ ] philly yeah i thought
you were philly trash i didn't know you
were
i love it i don't know i love when
people start realizing that i'm not just
i'm gonna look at you completely
different you have to but yeah if you
came in and told you that you dropped
out of high school yeah in ninth grade
and started working i would have been
got somebody pregnant or something yeah
like yeah
yeah no none of that none of it close
none of it and where'd you grow up
you grew up outside right well i i've
lived in south philadelphia i was like
seven eight and then my parents my dad
moves down to um
uh media in delco gotcha right yeah
which one it was
all right now it's super [ __ ] nice
yeah yeah yeah a lot of money rolled
into that oh yeah
see it's funny because i just realized
there's a whole season in intervention
that's about kensington oh yeah and
upper darby
and it's funny because there's a whole
season heroin hub
and that's you know and it's you know
it's nothing we haven't seen but it's
like it's showing them all coming down
to upper darby
and my brother's sitting there just
pulling his hair out because he's got a
house down there he's trying to remodel
and he's just seen it
yeah there's another thousand there's
another thousand yeah no
i went to theater school right next to
uh media in rose valley
oh yeah all right and that's real
[ __ ] yeah it's real that's
real real wealthy rich people yeah it's
weird media and upper providence
in that that area used to be i'm not 100
sure now but it used to be like
okay it was working middle class but
then there was spots
out you know they were [ __ ] nice dude
yeah but we didn't live there did you
grow up in a single family home
yes yeah we had to roll home and then we
moved to a
three bedroom one and a half bath that's
not bad it was nice you and your brother
share a bedroom oh yeah yeah
until when college uh yeah yeah when he
left
two single beds were they bunk beds
singles two singles yeah side by side
yeah a little you know the little uh
strong table in between yeah me remember
they did that for a while
yeah it's like all through high school
that's tough what was the yeah what was
that well the good thing was i was a
freshman when he was a senior so i only
and he was never home so it was like a
half a year and then he was out
and he went to west virginia oh nice all
right i said i'd make the uh squeaky
squeaky situation a little
yeah just do wet work hit the shower i
know i thought i was classy i'd put the
two singles together when he left
that did not last and so i was like yes
so trashy oh yeah
that is a [ __ ] poor man more man's
king-sized bed
get a queen-fitted sheet outside trying
to put pillows in the crack so it's not
[ __ ] terrible yeah it was my first
time i had my own room so i was like
yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] spruce this up
and yeah that's
trash anybody in your family ever have a
water bed uh yeah my cousin
my cousin frank did not your parents
though no no
i didn't know anybody who had them uh
yeah yeah
greek kid yeah greek pants those parents
were [ __ ]
yeah it was i mean you walked into the
room there's a shag carpet like [ __ ]
three feet high carpet
yeah and it had the poles on the four
corners like the canopy people get
strapped up on those things those things
are
so trashy yeah the canopy get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] that is a
garbage
all right let's play a little are you
garbage let's [ __ ] ask some questions
here let's get it
very very interesting i i don't know if
you really if you
revealed all this we didn't get into
that last time no we went dude
honestly my perspective has completely
changed i thought you were like full
blown dirt bag yeah you're normal
rough around the edges you know i got an
image to maintain but you know
i think i put on the dirt tracks yeah he
was wearing a three-piece suit
with an armani suit he's like charlie
chaplin takes off the makeup
oh very good um i'm trying to think of
where to start here with this
what about now what it would you don't
you rent right
yeah you live by yourself no two
roommates two roommates okay yeah you're
more garbage now than probably europe oh
absolutely no 401k
in that no no i'm hoping this settlement
is a little bigger than that are you
are you on the lease uh yeah are you the
leaseholder or
uh two of us are all the dudes is on
just in there yeah you're the guy not on
the lease i've been the guy
not only very similar to your situation
like at south philly house it's like a
comics house yeah people are in and out
you know like shane and mccusker and
o'connor have all lived there at one
point and then they filter out and
couple more come in
yeah you know how it is that was like
for the listener foley used to live in
my basement next to the washing machine
it was a stand up not a bad unit put
that thing on fire that was that was my
that was my calm app
[ __ ] go night night throw the [ __ ]
uh i lived there for
three months upstairs
[Music]
there was a comic house in philly and it
was in south philly and
it was me and my me and my two buddies
originally got the house and then foley
moved in and then another comic moved in
and the third floor was like the master
suite the whole third floor
jacuzzi tub your own marble bathroom
hardwood floor walk-in closet
walk dude that thing was [ __ ] nice
that was nice i forgot about that
walking closet in the hallway bigger
than the other room
i was in i was in a bad way back there
too i was like a 35 year old man i was
[ __ ] living with some other comic
and the whole place smelled like cat
piss my parents were freaking out
i wasn't frank hippie uncle hank would
have been on the [ __ ] streets
also too that was that wasn't that bad
of a neighbor like the other side of
brazil
it could get dicey though yeah so like
your own like point uh
what are you you're on the left side if
you're coming down broad you're on the
left side yeah
so like the the right freeze yeah yeah
yeah it can get a little dicey
but foley for he moves in he's like
finally he's tall
holy you know he thinks he's like the
[ __ ] star [ __ ] linebacker and
still in his horse
and he's like listen now that the big
dog's here you don't have to [ __ ]
worry about it don't lock the doors yeah
yeah
don't anything any problem comes i got
it you know
dude within like three days of him being
in the house our one roommate gets the
[ __ ] kicked out of them
on the front step on the side in the
back the two dudes just rolled off oh
just walked up and jumped
always snoozed on the couch to the whole
[ __ ] thing you're upstairs like
you're in the basement maybe because i
know that house later i'm a heavy
sleeper buddy he'd got his [ __ ] ass
kicked screaming for help
this was pre-sleep apnea guy look up
like
foley's out there in [ __ ] dreamland
yeah that's crazy because that's like a
dead end right they followed
down the dead end and then once you're
in that dead end that's like a michael
jackson movement
i can't get out of there one way in one
way out patio
all right all right yes here we go let's
play a little [ __ ]
it's always fun when you got a pal you
know it's like yeah it's good you just
you just get into it
you ever play on a uh on an intramural
softball team
no but i did play intramural deck hockey
team that we are currently
banned from for life wait hold on what's
deck hockey
that's just that's what it is it's out
of like a nice rollerblade rink but you
don't wear a nice one not a trash can
not like that [ __ ] behind you know
rickles used to be you know what i mean
this is behind
this is family fun spot very nice place
there's still rollerblade [ __ ] places
oh dude they get nuts on it but it's
like the rubber mat and back then it was
like we didn't all wear
we didn't rollerblade so we were like
you they just called deck hockey
so uh you play on your shoes yeah you
just don't want to street hockey yeah
you got to wear
gloves and a mask and uh wait a minute
wait they're changing lines taking [ __ ]
sharing we're just wearing trucks and
helmets
one guy's got a catcher's mask on yeah
wait those
no rollerblades no that's street hockey
yeah it's a street hockey
yeah how do what that yeah i mean i play
i mean
we played i was i played hockey all
grown up so i was like i get it yeah
street hockey
yeah man that's funny they just called
it deck hockey i don't know you know
what
would you like what'd you get for we
started a uh bench clear with a bunch of
construction workers
and uh my buddy will had a broken arm
that he covered up he wasn't even
supposed to be playing under his glove
and just teed off on a guy and then
long story short my buddy nikki's dad
he's climbing down the fence
he's going after a guy and then a girl
not a doctor i assume
no he wasn't looking to see if everybody
was all right and uh they called the
state cops on us
the state the troopers yeah state cops
rhode island yeah and then it dude it
was funny because my one buddy who was
supposed to do that and i didn't show it
he showed up the next week to be like
see what was going on he's like yeah you
guys
you guys pictures are behind the thing
you're [ __ ] i was like really he's
like yeah it's like they did a bank job
oh yeah look out for these
look out for these whole again [ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy's bowl fell out of his
pocket when he went down for the
face-off to start the game
his metal bowl falls out and we're like
what the [ __ ] take it these aren't
olympic athletes you're dealing with
you know we had a few in it how old are
you we were
like senior year high school and uh yeah
yeah it got it was like a no joke ball
like my buddy
bust this guy's nose wide open and then
we were like
these guys can [ __ ] us up dude so we
just started swimming construction
workers dude they're construction
workers strength
you're [ __ ] you're a high school kid
what are you playing against men for
these are dirty dirty people why aren't
you playing on like a like a like a like
a high school sport
i mean i was still playing high school
organized sports but this was just for
us to have fun on you know whenever
and this has to fight neighbors yeah we
had to beat up older fights
we got to play we had to play the uh
juvenile school too which was six
because they couldn't hit us they bust
them in
and uh which one glenn mills yeah glenn
mills actually just did a documentary
about that
shout out to glenn mills we used to play
those this sounds like the [ __ ]
trashy worlds
dude those dudes the longest yard with
adam sandler they
guys are playing the inmates dude they
were like unlv 94
they came in big i was like this guy's
[ __ ] 34 what does he do
two experiences with that when i was a
kid uh we pl i played cyo basketball and
one of the schools was the home for bad
boys
which was called it sounds hot it's a
ditty group
it's the hell of a breakdancer it was
called saint gabes and it was like a
[ __ ] prison
yeah and you went out there and what was
skill you're coming out there in like a
[ __ ]
you know you're going out in a minivan
with some some you know somebody's dad
you're petrified because as you pull
into the [ __ ] campus
you look across the highway and that's
where the graveyard is where they bury
them
oh yeah
white boy cemetery nobody gets that
straight
[ __ ] fighting and then and for some
reason glenn mills has a lacrosse team
yeah and they were terrible lacrosse but
they would they were dudes would come in
with like neck rolls oh they're huge
they just wanted like they just wanted
to hit that'll scare the [ __ ] out of you
it'll look like a croc like he was
wearing like a dress dude
on some football he feels so scary
right we're doing two hands those guys
came in probably had like four lines
of offense we barely had two yeah we
didn't know the [ __ ] was showing up you
know what i mean so like these guys
would come in our bus and they would
only let us play them because we are the
closest in age to them
which i think uh they were lying because
there was a couple dudes i was like this
guy works at the boat
what are you doing here dude yeah that
was always when you pull up to see the
other team
i remember doing it in in roller hockey
and i don't know jeff bryn athen there
was like a big there was a
there was a big rink there there's used
all the big tournaments yeah but
i remember pulling up it was under 16
was the rule like you know what i mean
so we're like 14 50
dude this one dude one of the teammates
on the other team drove
half the team there and like he pulls up
with like the lanyard and the keys i'm
like this guy
this is a man my nuts hadn't even
dropped yet i got a little beach buzz
about to get my [ __ ] ass kicked my
apparently my parents would have let me
done something like that if you're doing
anything that's not
school sanctioned travel team township
team
or as you get older if you're playing in
one of the softball leagues or [ __ ]
basketball
that's garbage that's all well as a kid
a lot of
teams a lot of schools don't have hockey
teams or like they did
yeah but they stunk and our two friends
that were really good they played for
like the quakers
yeah yeah yeah it was all like that's
all club sports and that's all we had to
do was get them the ball they were
firing [ __ ] 100 mile per hour shots
from the other side and we'd be half in
the back hockey attracts a garbage
garbage people especially with no skates
[ __ ] yeah
dude they're just tough man like when
you have limited players like i said
glenn mills they had [ __ ] they had
line changes
we're on the side [ __ ] huffington
post and this is cranking
oh yeah that was one of the games we
only brought one water bottle we used to
bring like two water bottles with like
whiskey one with whiskey one with like
rum and coke
and then like four water bottles and we
forgot any water
and we were just pounding whiskey i was
like i just need liquid this will work
assistant oh yeah senior year but the
best part was they couldn't hit us
they physically could not contact us
one dude did walk by my buddy though
after he hacked him in the leg
and he was like wait am i coaching
looking he's like i'm so sorry dude i
was like yo dude
i'm so sorry the breaks yeah you my bad
dude
i know i was like sorry man are you a
have you ever cooked out in public have
you ever used like a public grill at a
park come on baby
grassy family reunion every summer in
the cape may public zoo
everybody in the zoo in the zoo dude
that zoo is [ __ ]
trash come on that's good you gotta give
donations to get in
come on dude they got a lion that smokes
everybody look at the [ __ ] liar hey
kid keep it moving huh
you've never seen a grown man in a lion
costume before go look at the penguins
it's a dirty bird seagull spray painting
that's a [ __ ] real trap i don't i
haven't been in a while
but there's a picture of me wait wait
wait stop stop stop what a [ __ ] zoo
it's my dad's side because the family's
so big my grandmother's like it's
family's too big half of them live there
yeah and i think we've we've worn them
yeah we've worn out our welcome at a few
years
woman flipping eggs and we you it would
have been vfw or fire
uh house you know how it goes but i
honestly i think the family's too big so
they always do in the summer at the cape
may zoo
in there it's great what would you do
you'd walk around the zoo
uh yeah just get drunk and then wait for
a fight to break out like always
you wouldn't you you'd pay to get into
the zoo the zoo i don't think you pay
donation donation it's free to go to
cape may zoo
but the zoo has a designated picnic yeah
it's a big picnic area with grills
would you reserve that or just show up
and see what happens uh a couple times
we just
we just went in and took our grinders
yeah we just went like columbus style
dudes came in and [ __ ] and you
wouldn't utilize the facilities at the
zoo you would just go there to have a
cookout just the grill and the lawn part
and then
so if i had called level five called you
on on a date hey where are you at oh i'm
at the zoo having a hamburger with my
family yeah
wow world dude goes to a zoo and doesn't
go to the zoo
you guys are tailgating this dude yeah
dude they made shirts up every year
great we do ours we might have talked
about this we do ours on north wildwoods
beach
which one that's at least we go like 14
15
like 14th street and we just get like 10
tents
we sent we sent like a group of cousins
down there super early
they claim [ __ ] steak in the back and
then it's just like [ __ ] we got a
bunch of hot dogs going a bunch of
[ __ ] boys
what billy grill we bring them we bring
them i was gonna say all right just the
way he says that little girl down
he got excited yeah he's growing a piece
down here what street yeah we live
closer to 14th street than the [ __ ]
zoo i'll tell you that
i assume these grills were not uh they
were not smokers traeger
park ones that just had like the pole up
there's just very little they're burning
old shoes
this is the trash can we cut in half
[ __ ] hooverville
[Laughter]
what is this seabiscuit this is your
[ __ ] my horse is a little tender
today
and one uncle's going after the chickens
and [ __ ]
anybody want duck hey aunt dilly try the
skunk it's freak
[ __ ] that we were trying yeah we were
trying to cook the [ __ ] zoo animals
dude we went there's a picture of us at
that zoo in the 90s where we all it's me
my cousins my brother my we all look
like joe dirt even though
yeah i'll get it and i'll post it we all
look like [ __ ] joe dirk
you have to to get in there dude we're
all sitting there in a [ __ ] that lie
it's the saddest [ __ ] lion and he's
walking back and forth
and i don't know what defense situation
was but he peed
all over all of us [ __ ]
heavy streams oh that scar he's like 90.
he don't know yeah we woke him up won't
happen every animal there is sad as [ __ ]
that's
[ __ ] terrible nothing because it's
bad conditions it's fine it's just they
can't i don't think they can afford to
get you know the good stuff
yeah they're eating your leftover
[ __ ] hot dogs guys they're feeding
them [ __ ]
feeding them premier sausage that's good
sausage
no you don't get that you don't get that
good stuff i don't know if that's a
national bread but i'll tell you what
you get a couple of those premium sweet
screwed the hots all day
lots of [ __ ] girls don't burn you on
the way out but they ain't dude
it's worth it oh man we had a i saw a
picture of
my family recently uh we did dude a
family reunion at the cape may zoo
[ __ ] tough it's 11 40. penn state
dude
you should see yeah they did they do a
family picture too it's hilarious
just screaming at each other but in the
80s in the 80s there was a bunch of like
public events that like they wanted
everybody to be involved in like you
know like live aid but they had this one
called hands across oh yeah yeah yeah
where we you know same same thing i
always say we took like four
cars we drove out on the bypass like a
jerk we did it at our elementary
school i think it was like we did it
during school just in a big circle
yeah we're just like all right we're
doing it i guess yeah yeah we did and
there's a photo of us that you
yeah i look like i was [ __ ] scalping
tickets [ __ ]
[ __ ]
my nuts hanging out of my [ __ ] short
shorts oh
hi high socks are bad dude those striped
blue and red eyes
[ __ ] damn that's garbage yep man
good times that is something do you guys
still do the family reunion every summer
can we come in
absolutely i'm coming that's bonus it's
good food dude you'd be in [ __ ]
heaven my friend
you ever have giraffe foley come on
aunt rita puts a foot in it i'll tell
you that what i'd love to know what's
what what's the what's the what's the
big hit that like your family functions
as far as what like an aunt or an uncle
will make like
a food that you're looking forward to
aunt shelly's because we've been playing
we've been talking about
we've been talking and people have been
sending the recipes for the are you
garbage cookbook uh a couple of reasons
he's pushing this cookbook like he's
[ __ ] emerald
it's not that's good though i would
never categorize
i mean it's a trashy event right hands
down
trashy as [ __ ] the food though forget
about this classy oh my god what are we
talking talk to me so
it's always like my aunt teresa's
lasagna is always good wait a minute
come on dude come on
i don't care how good she is she can't
eat lasagna
at a zoo you can though you got to go
quick at a public
public park in a zoo it's sweating by
the time the foil comes off
but it's good you guys set up like
sternos and [ __ ] oh
come on yeah have the wedding there
sterno
almost positive my cousin almost did get
married there almost
i'm almost i couldn't afford to deposit
it no she opted for the firehouse
because i don't know
about it weekend opened up that's nuts
oh my god
holy all right so your aunt's lasagna
lasagna um
and meatballs my accused meatballs are
really good
and the fact that you're going full
italian is yeah
my dad's whole side is that's all yeah
do you have
uh do you have any aunts or uncles where
you don't call them by their real name
oh yeah like an ant
that's my mom's side uh we got tori
uh tony
[Laughter]
my mom's side who's the irish that's
where we changed the names
and it's uh yeah it's aunt mamie
um what else jojo uh
and jojo yeah jojo oh my god yeah yeah
what's her real first name
today is matilda all right mimi is mary
okay and jojo is franklin kathryn
i don't know where they got that one
the weirdest thing i didn't test my mom
[ __ ] i should have wrote down their
middle names
are absurd it's just straight gaelic
and if you've ever heard gaelic it
sounds like a russian throwing up
yeah or irish whatever the [ __ ] you want
to call it
but it's horrible and that's their
middle names are very
very catholic oh dude yeah the gaelic
freaks me out like what the [ __ ] was
ireland before before
a prisoner before the roman catholics
rolled in yeah that's
funny i got an aunt soupy soupy and an
aunt quinny
yeah they both owe you money
[Laughter]
soupy and quinny oh that's [ __ ]
adorable
are any of them not married uh all of
them like the
oh one's widowed and the other ones uh
toady never got married dude tony can't
keep a man yeah no no she never wanted
one she had a husband tony's totally
wanted
one aunt joe you guys are scrolling
through tinder you come across teddy
oh definitely she's definitely smoking a
noop in her profile
no no they smoke uh winchesters oh
winchesters yeah yeah and they have them
in the purse they're from ireland so
it's like these are my greatest
yeah yeah yeah there was eight of those
there was eight sisters and three
brothers my grandma they have their
little purse the little
oh yeah on my dad's side too come on
that comes standard if you want to have
a barbecue at a cape may zoo
you better have them in a [ __ ] pack
who's got my winnies my aunt jerry's got
her name on hers
oh my gosh
oh yeah those in the stand-up ashtrays i
remember like
my grandparents house and they would
have a stand-up ashtray
that was just it just smelled like this
is this is one that we
uh we've been talking about recently
when you would go out to dinner with
your family or whatever would you get
smoking or none
uh depends on what side of family was it
was my dad's i was always smoking my
mom's
they weren't big smokers or they just go
outside you know your parents smoked
no which is crazy because both their
parents were heavy smokers
but the irish don't like cigarettes
while they eat whereas my dad's side can
literally chew with one in their [ __ ]
mouth
they don't give a [ __ ] yeah that's
pretty weird man as fat as i am i i
can't
i hate it it's disgusting yeah here i
got this my friends will do this which
is
i think is garbage we'll all go out to
eat you know there'll be like five or
six of us
and they'll like get the appetizer and
then they'll leave to go smoke a sig
like they'll leave the table before
before like in the middle
like before the entree comes yeah
they'll like they'll go smoke two cigs
during dinner
i feel like there's drugs involved at
that point no i mean sometimes there is
for sure but i'm just saying
they'll do it i'm gonna go smoke a cig
and they just leave the table i'm like
whoa whoa whoa
well yeah yeah i'll just get up and
leave the [ __ ] restaurant yeah he's
big on that he doesn't like when i do
that like sometimes we'll
go into a coffee place like you know you
know running around you know waiting to
do spots or something like that
well going to a coffee place will sit
we'll write or whatever
if like halfway through i want to go out
and have a smoke
he doesn't want to come back in he
thinks that's garbage
you're straight i think that's classy
this is you're stretching it out a
little bit
you're just getting coffee and waiting
it's like different we're done eating or
drinking whatever we are like
our exchanges we bought a coffee and a
pastry sure we've consumed it
yeah we're now leaving he wants to go
back in and like sit down again
nah i mean it depends on how long i'm
leaving my stuff there
yeah i don't know that one's tough
because it's not a full meal so it's
kind of just a casual thing you said
you're waiting in between spots it's
like yeah whatever
the after appetizers thing that's
[ __ ] weird
i have to eat everything then after
dinner smoking
what about going out for a smoke while
you're waiting for the espresso and
dessert
after you have the meal no you're you're
there you're
if you look around no one else is doing
that yeah there are people this is
nobody's
outside the restaurant as a [ __ ]
smoke are you sitting at a bar to eat
are you sitting in it
i'm at a table there's people like
waiting to get the
table to burn and turn you got a [ __ ]
waitress you're outside [ __ ] smoking
they don't take that into account that's
trash
i don't know i think it's pretty classy
while you're waiting for your tiramisu
yeah go out and [ __ ] smoke it all an
already half smoked [ __ ] marlboro red
that you
that you put out in your pack before you
went in oh i hate that but yeah how
gross is it when you're sitting down and
somebody does go out and smokes and
comes back in
that [ __ ] cigarette oh yeah yeah
that's the worst yeah you got lobster
mac and cheese hanging out of your mouth
um you're eating nice dude tiramisu
how much [ __ ] the balls man paying
you over here jesus christ that's
uh promo code yes sir you were dollar
slice when i knew you
uh have you ever owned a zippo oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's
i never all right here's the thing
though i never bought one it was always
either given to me
uh like where i took it from like my
brother or something one of my cousins
yeah one won an arcade that was huge
yeah yeah
oh yeah oh yeah how many tickets is that
it's like twenty thousand dude it's fun
cake like 80 bucks
spent 900 bucks yeah
yeah i got a red zippo from [ __ ] ed's
funkade in the 90s
oh i thought i was i thought i was were
you smoking
i don't think at the time no light
though you were like
oh baby or the snap
did you open it snap because i didn't
know you could do that so i would go
like this
and that's yeah like an [ __ ] yeah i
didn't know dudes could be like boom
boom
i forgot about the [ __ ] zip oh my
buddy would do that all the time with a
zippo that had no [ __ ] fuel in it i'm
like what are you doing he's like
naughty kids hanging out zippo's zippo's
are pretty classy i gotta be honest with
you that they were always classy but
then yeah
they got real trashy in the 90s but they
before that they were classy yeah they
were like prestigious it was like you
were a gentleman
smoking like here's my lighter yeah not
this disposable thing but like
dude if you're like outside a bar and
someone pulls out like a grateful dead
zippo or yeah
like hit the bricks and you know it's
always creepy too because they they
always want to be the one to light it
they don't hand you the lighter
yeah they want to do the whole thing i
got you
yeah my buddy kevin was like that he had
one of the goals in front of your face
spun the top you remember those ones
yeah there's like a gold one though and
he was the trashiest kid i knew we'd be
like love park skateboarding he'd be
like i'll get it for you i'm like why do
you have that [ __ ] life yeah what are
you doing we got 24 calories
like and that just puts it in place i
was going to say that
i knew the first time i saw a butane
letter you say what you want about me
my family i'm garbage i'm disgusting the
second i saw my first butane lighter i
said to myself
that's [ __ ] garbage right there those
things i'll do one better
than my friend they are dangerous i had
not one
but two shout out to wildwoods boardwalk
in the 90s
two uh butane gun lighters
oh yeah like yeah yeah what the
the no the wind resistant yeah the wind
resistant [ __ ] i was toasting
bernie's dude
who wants something i need a smoke in a
tornado
[Laughter]
did you have the case no case but i had
two [ __ ] metal guns they were like
did you pull them out
oh dude i was [ __ ] wider i thought i
was so cool at parties
riding a bumper car down the boardwalk
yeah shane
holding up the [ __ ] frozen yogurt
hippie holiday over here
fastest fastest drone
i'll say this to any novelty lighter of
any kind yeah is [ __ ]
drastic yeah that's what we're trying
yeah yeah
smoking you get older more and figure
out that either you get it stolen or you
[ __ ] lose it it's like who gives a
[ __ ] yeah
i gave up on having a nice lighter
[Music]
man that's some [ __ ] man i tell you
what we got some
folks today's episode is brought to you
by the good people at sheath
underwear i got them on right now
they're the best underwear i've ever had
listen it's the summer it's hot it's
sweaty out there you might be walking
around dealing with some hot balls right
now
nobody likes a hot sweaty ball
nobody nobody on only fans nobody
anywhere
all right perhaps you got a little ass
sweat too that's no good either
perhaps you're listening to this
thinking to yourself you wish you could
remove all your clothing and just let
the boys flap in the breeze
you're sick of boxers they're too loose
or briefs are too tight
they're choking your nuts you got to
shift them around listen as a big guy
that shit's a pain in the ass all right
and just do me a favor here
listen to me hear me out cause what we
have to recommend to you is sheath
underwear it's the softest most
comfortable boxer brief
that i personally have ever worn and
i've had them all over the world i'll
tell you that right now
chief is going to help you beat the
summer ass sweats and the thigh
chafing now i have to use a special roll
on to keep the chafing down but when i
wear my sheath underwear
don't even need it that's how good they
are the fabric just has like this silky
feel to it
and it keeps everything cool and
comfortable and in place
yeah it's literally become my favorite
underwear and i'm mad when they're all
dirty
so here's what makes sheath unique it's
got a pouch so you can separate it's a
system of pouches it's like the [ __ ]
matrix it's got a pouch
so you can separate your balls from your
inner thighs which is to me
a game changer then on top of that
there's this second shaft pouch that
separates further the frank and the
beans or the dick and the balls when
desired
sometimes i go in pouch sometimes i go
out of pouch you know what i mean keep
you on your toes a little bit sometimes
my girlfriend can't find you who knows
what's happening
this is this is huge for the summer it's
a game changer especially if you're
outside
working out now for some of you think
you might not be interested in
separating your man parts
i still recommend sheath you can wear
them like any other boxer
box or boxer brief and it's crazy
comfortable it makes me feel sexy too
you know what i mean it feels like a
little like boom
boom boom i feel like i lose 30 pounds
every time i put them all for the record
i like them dirty
and they look fantastic they come in all
different patterns and stuff it's great
sheath makes it look like you're packing
or if you're packing it makes it look
like you're really packing
so for me it looks like i'm packing
uh so go to sheathunderwear.com to get a
pair of the most comfortable underwear
you'll
ever own and if you use the code garbage
that g-g-a-r-b-a-g-e
you'll get 20 percent off your order we
ain't talking 10
we ain't talking 15 we're talking 20
percent
that's sheath underwear.com use promo
code
garbage now back to the show real
garbage
have you ever had a padded or wooden
toilet seat had it
oh we had it when we first moved uh when
we first moved into the new place
and it was great having a bigger dad
because first sit down in the summer
he's like this thing's gone
i'm not [ __ ] that in my life i know
if he's sticking
this [ __ ] thing sucks i remember yeah
he [ __ ] hated it those were like
medicinal they should have those in
would sit down it's like dude the air
would creep out look at it speaking of
toddy aunt
antonio penny one she had the pennies oh
my god yeah
yeah i don't even know what that is the
pennies encased in the toilet seat
you've never seen that yeah
she was a big slot she wanted she wanted
those things are
such [ __ ] trash imagine being so
trashy play the slots at harrah's
win a toilet seat at the [ __ ] casino
take it home and install it in your
house she was so proud
that was self-installed too that was not
a general contract yeah oh my god if i
know anything about today she knows her
way around toilet seat she knows what
she's doing
that's those are trashy and we were
talking about this the other day the
the money bouquets oh yeah are such
there was like 100 stuck somewhere and
the rest were all ones we never did
that is [ __ ] trash we had a hologram
on the top of our toilet seat
and our this was not that long ago that
was when me gillis and the customer
was a prince that was an eagle that
turned into a wolf
oh my god so when you open it it was a
wolf or whatever when you look at it
with a woofer when you open it would
turn into an eagle fly
what the [ __ ] okay
[Music]
it was pretty sweet we left it there
don't touch anything when you leave
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] the trashiest thing i've
ever heard of yeah it was brutal
did you ever know anybody or any of your
family ever have uh the beads
in the doorway yeah my
oh older cousins when they came together
it was like a jamaican flag with a
weedly
god yeah that's like spencer's gifts
right now oh yeah yeah give me
those and i remember for a while
people's dads my dad never [ __ ] with it
but they had the beaded
car seats oh we had that and the second
time oh yeah yeah
dude those things were [ __ ]
trash yeah they didn't do they just
heated up too i don't know what the [ __ ]
i remember getting in a buddy's car and
his dad had that i'm like
who has this my dad did it in the yellow
uh
chevy citation he used to have actually
a yellow car is tough
that's got house paint on it if you had
the car where you got made fun of
for getting dropped off oh the citation
had to be
you're showing up in a [ __ ] xanax
dude
pulling up in a perk tent like a couple
of school buses on my hands
no it was never that one that you
dropped off it was always the arrow star
we had the minivan oh
dude those things always smelled like
eggs you couldn't help it they always
smelled like [ __ ] eggs
they had bad catalytic converters yeah
yeah we had that
but that was always a drop-off car my
dad loved the [ __ ] citation what
color was the
van black with a uh brown and red
racing stripe down the side not thin
though not 18. i'm not trying to make an
overstatement
yeah 94 all paid up dude holy [ __ ] all
right we got to get out of here in a
couple of minutes here kippy what what
else you got here
i mean i'm pretty dead but
i mean i'll do this for shits and
giggles have you ever used a can of coke
to get a discounted mission to six five
for 37 people you guys are all you guys
that got a [ __ ] case of coke in the
parking lot no i never did
i remember that those promotions but i
never i remember thinking of myself like
[ __ ] save these and i never did have
you ever traded a tray lasagna
to get to get into an amusement park to
get into a zoo
you gotta grease the guy at the gate
with a little mana gut i did try and
uh trade weed for good monopoly pieces
when they were doing that whole thing at
mcdonald's because my buddy worked the
drive through and i was like can you
give it a little sneak peek
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'd get free
berries i throw them a dime
holy [ __ ] yeah you know what i always
thought was tracy you're talking about
uh
uh do you guys ever do beer can chicken
beer what do you mean oh yeah before
they put the beer can in the chicken or
whatever
what yeah is that where you like cook it
in the hood of your car or whatever
what do you think the main dishes over
the uh cape may zoo baby well you put a
beer in it she thought that was the
have you heard of this beer can chicken
like it was the fanciest thing
she's using a pounder like a [ __ ]
degenerate shotgun
before she's like 40. yeah you take a
chicken and i guess you fill it up with
the
leave half the beer filled and you stuff
the chicken on top of it
and then you stand it up on the grill
your mom's saturday night
oh and you cook it in there and
apparently the beer soaks into the meat
yeah it doesn't just [ __ ]
that's true that was big down the shore
barbecue so i remember we tried that
that's crazy trash
yeah that was that was bad wow yeah have
you ever worn a no fear t-shirt
no actually i [ __ ] hate it no fear
good
all right he's making him he's making a
rally here in the night see-saw's coming
around
get your rally caps on boys uh just
cause these have been these have been
hot bus
button issues going around the ru
garbage community lately we'll ask you
do you brush your teeth in the shower
i used to i don't know anymore i used to
though in high school i did what made
you stop
he got his [ __ ] act yeah i was like i
don't want to do this i used to also
drink beer in the shower a lot
come on we're gentlemen you know you
ever do mixed drink in the shower that's
tough dude if you're doing like a rum
and coffee i did do that a couple times
a [ __ ] captain and ginger i remember
like catching myself like what the [ __ ]
am i doing that's tough
yeah in the shower with your [ __ ]
monster i put it down next to like the
three in one shampoo conditioner
well the thing about the beer is it's
tough for water to get in there you
gotta
if you got an open [ __ ] yeah oh i was
running up like [ __ ] atomic
charcuterie plate yeah i'm going there
with like snifters do you bite your
nails or clip your nails
right do you uh pick your teeth with
your nails yes
oh with the cut with the bit now you'll
then dig yeah and those
not like those answers came off like you
were expecting the questions
i kind of was i assumed that was going
to be one that is a tough pick your nose
nah no not really i mean if i have to if
i can do a little if you can
scratch your nuts you smell it no no
smell me either
[Laughter]
so yes buy me a coke he sniffs his i
smell mine
other way around whatever how do you
feel about the filet of fish sandwich
i hate it really yeah he's [ __ ] i
hate to play a fish i hate it i stick to
the classics that all [ __ ] take on
all
fast food the mcrib was disgusting uh
there was a lobster good [ __ ]
yeah it's good they're not getting the
food there they're bringing that
the mcdonald's when you come over the
rio grande they use that old school like
doo-wop one
they have a [ __ ] they used to have a
lobster roll sandwich
my buddy ate it and then we went out of
my dad's boat to go fishing he made it
maybe three minutes up the harbor and
it's like
he just was pissed [ __ ] and puking off
the back
and i was he's like i don't know what it
could be just jammed the [ __ ] lobster
roll
from mcdonald's at seven in the morning
down your throat that some [ __ ]
crackhead just made
wait where was this was this in philly
no no it was in wawa
it was down the shore they've never
offered i've never seen it anywhere else
that was just something that the chef
made that yeah that was like a shamrock
shake you know what i mean it comes
around it's like haley
white trash haley's comet all right uh
if you're at mcdonald's
and you order you know you get a drink
you get a soft drink will you ever order
a soda with no ice
no i used to do that i was big no isis
why
i don't know because i was just like oh
you get more i don't know
we never really had soda growing up that
is f that's the en
that's inherent trash right yeah you're
getting an extra mouthful of coke by
the gentleman thing is either get the
water cup that's what i use that's just
dude that a spend the 2 000 spend 1.59
like a [ __ ] gentleman nope
i refused oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
yep yeah dude now i was i but now yeah i
have to go ice i have to
yeah you got to go oh yeah come on what
the [ __ ] who's drinking that warm syrup
get out of here can you ask him before
we get out of here i want to know his uh
his go-to appetizers can you okay
so we did this me and foley are a big
big casual dining establishment guys we
like popping into a bar getting a couple
of beers couple of apps you know what i
mean not this big not like a whole uh
whole to do but you know we're talking
bar apps i'm talking about
the fine establishment known as tgi oh
right yeah this is the app menu at tgi
friday's
pick your top two go ahead you got your
mozzarella sticks
you got your spinach and artichoke dip
chips and salsa
warm pretzels pan seared pot stickers
uh green bean fries get the [ __ ] out of
my face
friday's signature whiskey glazed sesame
chicken strips
panko breaded a friday signature whiskey
glazed sampler
poof wait no sampler no sampler take the
sample around no
because that's that's that's the cheap
you're going for the sampler
of course yeah of course that's why i
took it all i forgot that better come in
a bowl i can eat too
ground round you stab member ground
round buddy let me tell you something
i st every time i smell hamburger it
takes me back to the
[ __ ] the ground round oh loved it uh
loaded potato skins
or friday's signature whiskey glazed
sliders which are usda
choice beef burgers whiskey glazed
roasted onions
white cheddar and spicy may spicy mayo
made with tabasco chipotle pepper sauce
served with seasoned fries yeah i would
stick with the uh whiskey covered
both of them the signatures really i'm
not a big
you know what i hate is stuffed the
potatoes things what
yeah what i've never liked the [ __ ]
the guy who eats at the zoo
i mean no i do not i mean i can eat them
don't get me wrong
i can eat them can you eat it if i have
my sticks if i have to what about the
twice baked potato that you used to be
able to get
the twice baked i would probably do that
baked potato it's just i'm talking about
the ones with the [ __ ]
you know frozen cheese over with the
bacon bits buddy sign me up all day long
dude you love them baked potato head
over oh
yeah i feel like my mic's off is my mic
off there b i hear you buddy i think it
might be you're hearing me i sound good
yeah you're good i guess my headphones
going i'd go whiskey glazed
on the meat and whiskey glaze on the
chicken not the pot stickers
i like stickers i mean i like mod sticks
but if you know
if that's if there's other options
what's embarrassing on there is the
chips and salsa and
chips and salsa at a friday's
yourself if you're paying for chips and
salsa you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah
go to a mexican joint get them on a cuff
wise guy never pays for chips and salsa
i've been watching a lot of donning
brassica recently
holy [ __ ] go through the [ __ ] i got
him
yeah i'm just walking who won the war
like what war
like yeah that's the most confusing
scene i've ever seen in my life what we
talked about
when he's like take your boots off he's
like hey who won the whole who won the
war
i just stopped anybody who knew anything
about the war like they did
[ __ ]
dude sonny says it best decree he goes
how did he
stands up tightens his body yeah listen
my friends are gonna take his shoes off
it's just like the most dismissive like
shopkins why do you go against the
[ __ ] table yeah
all right brian six yes i mean 100
yeah yeah he rallied in the beginning
the [ __ ] penn state
[ __ ] 1140 as someone who also has an
eleven hey goodwill hunting took a
[ __ ] decent test too he was still
[ __ ]
[ __ ] boston trash yeah you saw his
house
oh man you're [ __ ] off and it catches
me you're trash baby you're 100
garbage we [ __ ] love you uh what do
you want the gang out there to know
oh i don't know listen to wi-fi podcast
uh news people have been dming me about
the cartoon
uh chris o'connor is making it awesome
yeah yeah great thank you yeah yeah it's
going great
uh actually he's recording up uh
the last couple of things right now so
it should be out within the next i'd say
two or three weeks
cool i don't even know what the [ __ ]
name of it is but you know if you check
uh my social media which is just at
brian six
uh i'll definitely have links and
updates to it yes so pump for that
yeah everybody should support brian
buddy like i said everybody wanted john
manson yeah they already know yeah they
got their phil
yeah they got sick yeah they got a
[ __ ] zoo i didn't try and come out
classy but yeah i knew that zoo was
lurking and i was like
you said outdoor bars dude aunt took me
i tell you what you tell what you want
about me and kippy we'll sniff out some
[ __ ] trash oh yeah i know
i mean there's no way around here what
are you doing over there
i'm leaning into it man i'm getting head
shots tomorrow i think i'm wearing this
yeah yeah i'm not shaving what's the
difference you've been wearing it the
past three weeks why change now i'm
going in
i'm go i'm going for for uh like
computer programmer hacker
works at nassau those kind of things i
can't play one of those guys
you should be going for [ __ ]
margaritaville
cheeburger cheeburger what do you got
kippy
uh at kevin ryan comedy on all social
media please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes get those [ __ ]
numbers up keep us in the top 20.
also full video available on youtube uh
you can subscribe there as well
and guys uh please submit your
uh garage your garbage garage fridge to
send an email to ru garbage gmail.com
and we'll take the top five
ten depending on you know we'll take the
top finalists and we'll review them on
the show
and you'll get some uh some free merch
out 30 second video just show us what
you got
show us what you got in there we're not
even sure whether we're gonna
get go for like you know if it's the
stack this one or for the trashiest
show us let's just see what you got on a
whim can i all right can i contribute to
that
of course i got a short one down body
lay it honestly i will bury you i might
let's i'll do
let's do our parents as well
i'm not giving my parents a free t-shirt
i'll tell you that they got enough nah
well you said you don't have the four
x's
sorry mom guys listen we love you and
speaking of t-shirts we do appreciate
everybody who bought uh bought a t-shirt
we love you guys we love doing all the
fan stuff um
this is going to be great i can't wait
to see how the garage fits plays out all
right you're rambling wrap it up all
right whatever
i'm excited i like this okay all right
we got the kid here we're having a good
time
gang we love you we'll see you next week